you're a very I've known you for quite a
while you're a very easy guy to talk to
I've also seen you interview many many
times you're very good interviewer are
you would you agree that you're an easy
guy to talk to do you think that that's
like that's just part of your I mean
besides the occasional long pause would
you say hey you hear anything at a time
well I like it I like show business just
like you I like comedy because it's the
rules are set up yeah that makes sense
life is unclear I don't know I know what
to do here I don't know what to do in
life most of life feels like arriving to
a party 20 minutes too late and the
social circles have already formed so
you're just kind of on the outside
satellite in a conversation looking for
your way in just like is a penny earned
thing an anecdote that end yes a penny
saying you had yeah you just had to wait
it out hey if you find what I've seen
stranger things
and they are in and then you're not
really in with I've seen strength your
things I'm not gonna get you in in my
experience Conan you're in ok
you